there's this viral video of a nurse and
it's like this viral tweet says
this is for all the covidiets who use
survival rate as like an excuse for not
following lockdown you saw this video
i did a video on it yeah she's like
imagine i've gave you like millions and
millions of skittles and then i told you
that 17 million would make you sick and
have lingering effects
and that 300 000 would kill you would
you still want to eat them
and i'm like okay hold on hold on how
many skittles were talking you said
millions upon millions
and then you said 99.9 are safe but 17
million will kill you
so that that doesn't make sense 17
million is point
one of the skills right okay so let's do
some math
more importantly though you mean to tell
me that you view
you know somebody working a man or woman
to feed their kids as eating candy
wow that that was the craziest thing to
me and i was like let me ask you a
question
if you were in the middle of the desert
and you were have gone without water for
a day or two
and you saw a pool of green murky water
and that's it
it will make you sick you'll probably
die would you drink it
absolutely you would yeah absolutely it
wouldn't even hesitate it wouldn't
wouldn't even happen who would but i
mean that's why the skittle analogy was
so terrible
because we look at people don't
understand when we mention the survival
rate we're talking about risk here
right that's what we're talking about
more than anything so
even with the skittle i don't think that
has a hundred press somebody's probably
died from i don't know diabetes from
eating skittles
choked on a skittle or something like
that so i don't delete them yeah exactly
so
people still eat them so i don't even
think that analogy is good that's
actually a good point
you you like i don't think uh you have a
one in a thousand chance of dying from
eating skittles but there is
likely you could die from eating
skittles easy absolutely
yeah and then people don't con she
didn't obviously i'll tell you this i
bet there somebody took a handful of
skittles and was chewing it
and had a big clump of skittles and then
choked on it i bet i bet
that's your bottom dollar that that's
happened to someone someone somewhere
but
that's what it's about it's about risk
it's about assessing the risk
really there's nothing in life that we
do where that has a hundred percent
survival rate you know where
you can trip down the stairs break your
leg get infected
have to get there's so many different
things you can drive your car
to work you can die in a crash all of
those things are risk
here's what i was saying about it uh
when she mentions you know the skittles
and the risk and the 0.1 percent
the people who want to work their jobs
aren't doing it because they're bored
right this is the crazy thing about the
left's argument supporting this
they think the people who need to work
jobs are doing it for fun
it's a weird view of work like people
work
yes for fulfillment but typically
because they have responsibilities
and they're and they're producing for
their themselves their friends and their
families
to survive so here's what i was thinking
take that logic of risk
and what risk you're willing to accept
and apply it to any other job
imagine if there's a firefighter and
then he saw a fighter and then this la
and another firefighter was like whoa
whoa whoa don't go in that burning
building
you might get burned well it's like well
yeah i realized that in fact
the likelihood that a firefighter going
into a burning building
will and gets burned in some capacity is
probably i'm not saying like serious
injury i'm just saying like
you might get sick you know there's risk
serious risk
and we often talk about you know
firefighters i think is the best example
i could do cops but i think firefighters
everybody generally likes you know
they know going into a burning building
substantial substantial risk
like i don't know if you guys ever seen
the movie backdraft i haven't seen it
since i was a little kid
but backdraft is i'm probably getting
the fire science wrong some of the
comments will correct me but
when when the when there's a fire and it
becomes oxygen starved
and then you open the door giving air to
the room then there's a big burst
and it and it hits you and so there's
things like that i remember i was told a
story by my dad who was a firefighter
for like 20 something years
you go on the roof and you'll hear
creaking and then all the firefighters
like look around at each other like what
do we do
and they train you if you hear creaking
if you get scared you get out you don't
wait for anybody else
because people will look to each other
and then not move but then the roof
caves in
so like these risks are legit and
imagine if
imagine if they all said we're sitting
around then the alarm went off and
they're like i don't know
man if i told you there were 100
buildings and one of them would be on
fire would you go in a building
it's like i probably would also she's
got some dumb analogy to skittles
and like she's talking about people's
livelihoods right so you got to take the
risk of going to work
it's not eating candy they're not going
to work for kids right i want to i got
to be mean
i got to be mean i don't want to be mean
but i got to bring up kyle kalinski and
i think kyle clinton is a good dude
he he's he's a good dude he's he's uh
you know he he doesn't i think he acts
in good faith and i respect him a lot
but he had this tweet that i got to
bring up and i'm not doing it i'm not
trying to be mean
but i don't know if you guys saw this
where he was in an airplane and he saw
all these farms he took a picture
and he was had something like so
beautiful i wonder why it looks like
this
and he got roasted like crazy because
people were like bro
like have you ever seen a farm before
and i felt bad because look man there's
a lot of people who deserve
they're nasty people they're mean on
twitter i don't care if you're left or
right there's a lot of really nasty
people now he's a good dude
and so him getting roasted hard i was
like come on man like he he
he tries to be good to people you know
if he got something wrong but it is a
good point
he's he's a progressive he's got a very
prominent popular youtube channel
and he didn't know what a farm looked
like and that says a lot
it does yeah because he's a thought
leader and so again i'm not trying to be
mean or disrespect for anything but just
think about that because i've had i've
had so many conversations with people on
the left
like like my friends who live in cities
there's no
they don't have the ability or i should
say the um
the experience and the knowledge or the
wisdom to connect
farms supply chain food in your
restaurants
it's like they've never put in an order
for food they don't know where it comes
from
you know what i mean so like when i'll
give you an example man we've been
trying people keep telling us albinis
right
they're like when you guys gonna sell
beanies well we can't get them made
first of all cove had made it really
really hard
but getting the specific product put
together like
designed properly not those nasty
acrylic garbage beanies you get at the
gas station or like a real
a real good one like the ones i'm
wearing you got to find
the place that makes them the place that
makes them has to get the right material
and so we call these companies and they
say we got to order from this place in
this part of the country
or even ordering skateboards like i was
doing that when i was a teenager
trying to figure out where the woods
being sourced from and then seeing where
that you know supply chain comes
many of these people on the left they
were telling me when i said
i kept telling people printing money
will not get you food and they were like
dude you can just go to the store and
buy it where do you think the food in
the store comes from it comes on a truck
so here's what people don't get people
who live in cities who don't understand
this
they've not run a business they've not
built or produced maybe they work
service jobs or they work digital
digital jobs
coding or media or whatever they don't
understand that that that supply chain
and so to them it's just the food
appears it's just in the store
and what they really don't get and this
is the crazy one is that when when the
coved pandemic hit there were a couple
weeks or about a month
where it seemed like everything was
normal you go to the store and there was
food and there was milk and there were
bagels and there was cream cheese
but then one day it was gone but it was
a delayed reaction why
the trucks were already being sent out
the shipments came in
docked at the ports load it up on trucks
the chipping containers
the trucks then start driving around the
country and it takes a certain amount of
there's a delay
so when they announce that they're doing
a lockdown you're not going to just go
to the store and everything's gone
because not only do they have a current
stock they have the weight the back room
stock then they have like three more
shipments you know next week the week
after
already lined up a month later
everything's gone yeah and you go into
the store and the toilet paper was gone
everyone's like oh what's happening oh
where's all the toilet paper it's like
yeah well i might bought something
that's why it's so easy for them to
demonize work though
you know um because they don't value it
and they don't understand
what people do and why how they do it
and why they produce them in the way
uh that they that they are i mean that's
the beauty of absolutely you know
absolutely when it comes to capitalism
that's the beauty for me and why i love
it so much and
unfortunately it support a lot of these
guys because yeah you can have virtually
no s
skill um not know how this stuff is
produced
but you can get something whether it be
a water bottle or something that you
have no idea how to purify water or
something but you bought it
it's yours uh now you can drink it you
can hydrate yourself
having not ever understood how you got
it
and a lot of folks skip that step
because they don't understand they don't
even care
to really understand that's why it's so
easy for them to say
why can't we just shut it all down and
then the government can just print money
to everybody
and they just give it to us while we sit
down and do nothing
it's so easy for them to say that
because they don't understand
why it is that we work they don't
understand production they don't
understand why it is that we produce
and it's so frustrating for me to see
people i was former collegiate athlete
and and seeing er my natural transition
was in the gym industry right out of
college
and to see that that be that was the
first thing to go
when it came to the lockdowns gyms it
was so
frustrating to me not only because i
understand like a lot of guys that own
gym
small and even franchise aren't really
usually rich anyway
uh uh like that and you get people put
their life savings and they're trying to
open up this gym they open up this gym
and then you say basically
well it's not safe for them to to do
what it is that they do well it's not
essential
now not only was that crazy because of
that but you know we definitely when we
learn more about the virus
and we know who was being impacted the
most you've seen
you think the gym was the place that
people wanted to go to try to get their
behinds in in some
sort of shape so they if they do
contract this virus they have a better
chance of
of surviving it but the gyms are the
first thing to go but it's just so easy
and how willy-nilly people just say shut
the gym down
shut the salon down it's no big deal we
don't need it we just leave these other
folks open and they don't understand
like
why it is that they're producing in the
way isn't there like an interesting
correlation between the idea that these
people don't know where food comes from
and also like the body positivity
movements and like privilege and all
this stuff they don't
understand the value of
not just like labor that produces for
the economy
but just good old fashion rolling up
your sleeves and working and the
benefits that come with it
like there there are people who do you
know uh you can you can farming is good
training
absolutely like actually just like
telling a field and doing work and then
you'll realize man you got crazy upper
body strength from it
a good a good hard day's work makes you
healthy makes you better we need it
they don't get that so now you've got
you know people who just
eat irresponsibly and assume the food's
just there and who cares and they don't
gotta do anything take care of
themselves
and this this ties into like universal
health care and stuff oh man
you know what man i was actually uh i
was even recently saying that i was very
much
in favor of universal health care if it
could be accomplished i like the idea
that we take care of everybody
and we got to figure out the right way
to do it and one of the arguments i've
often made is
like i think we talk about this ian like
if you break your arm you go to the
doctor they take care of you
you broke your arm it's not expensive
treatment it's like standard care but if
you get like
a serious cancer then you need private
insurance on top of that because that's
expensive to to produce and everything
like that but i'll tell you i changed my
mind on this
when i saw that they were giving uh for
the for covert vaccine
racial guidelines and then i was like
no way dude i'm out i'm out i'm totally
i'm totally off that wagon the thing
about me with the healthcare thing and
why i just can't take anybody serious
for advocating for it it's because
they certainly don't advocate for let's
say a mandate on top of the health care
that you would be required to like work
out or
exactly well that's that was a point i
wanted to make right like they don't
they don't make that a requirement they
don't even advocate that this is why you
have fascism yeah of course
like how like even though i think the
soviets made people do
calisthenics yeah like because obviously
you'd be less of a burden on the health
care system if the
the healthier you are but they don't
certainly pitch that as an
idea that's that's the thing about
authoritarianism if you were going to
say we're going to do universal health
care but the only way to make it work is
that everybody has to do a physical or
something or exercise
that would make sense and then you're
forcing people to do something yeah
it doesn't make sense to be like no no
no you can eat all the double bacon
triple cheeseburgers you want
and then we're all going to pay for your
house sugar they with food stamps you go
buy a pepsi and you can buy
all packages your entire food is insane
it's it's it's crazy man when i was
criminal when i was
addictive drugs when i was 20 but like
even even outside of that even outside
of like whether or not you want a rag on
sugar when i was 20
i had a food benefit card when i was
effectively i don't know i was homeless
in seattle
but i was like i moved there i was
pretty broke and i was like sleeping on
a couch
and i ended up getting a food card i got
a job really quickly within like a month
but while i didn't they gave me like 80
bucks
and i went into a store and they said
you can buy anything that isn't prepared
and i was like i can buy this
butterfinger like yeah i was like that's
insane
that's crazy why you get like buying
candy with it
it's sickness man it's it's it's like i
understand like
i think benefits are good like i
mentioned like i was helped by them
you know like i was able to i moved to
seattle and then you know
had a hard time and i was able to get
like 80 bucks for one month not a whole
lot of money didn't really do a lot for
me but it helped me eat and i didn't buy
candy bars with it
no but a lot of people do no that's like
exactly
what they buy i mean this is one of the
things that i
certainly learned uh when i i i went
into like a huge
out of college like this he was like
budgeting thing where i was like
i want to know how much money i'm
spending and spending it on what
and you just be surprised how much money
you spend on stuff that is not
obviously nutritious but more so how
much
it's not that it doesn't cost that much
to eat healthy it really a lot of people
think it does
but it really doesn't like you know the
amount of money like you go to i don't
know
a burger king or something and you get a
large meal you're gonna come out that
bad boy paying what like 10 bucks or
something like that
that for that that particular meal do
you know what you could get at the
grocery store
yeah for 10 bucks bananas what is a
banana like a dollar 29 a pound
packed with nutrients not a lot of
product you get you get a thing of
peanut butter you get a think of bananas
and you got
two three meals compared to what you get
chicken breast with
rice and a can of beans you have like
three meals exactly like four dollars
and we keep hearing
and it's healthier than that because
it's healthier than that this is what
really bothers me i think the modern
left
is is chock full of low information
individuals
who ruin the ideas of what the left is
supposed to actually be
arguing for economic cooperation versus
versus economic competition that's like
the easiest way i think to break down
what left and right would be
so i like the idea of social safety nets
the only problem is you have people who
are like
back back to this point i hear it over
and over again it's expensive to eat
healthy
and they and they have these videos they
put these viral videos where they're
like but wouldn't you rather just spend
a dollar at mcdonald's for a double
cheeseburger
when i lived in los angeles i was broke
and i was sharing a studio apartment
with some friends and i was making only
a couple hundred bucks a month you know
what i would do
for 80 cents i could get four tomatoes
and a thing of little a little thing of
mayo and then for another like 50 cents
i could get a pack of tortillas
there you go and that was that was just
like my snack for
for lunch or whatever but eating
tomatoes for like a dollar
i could have like 10 times the food
absolutely of a double cheeseburger and
i'll tell you this
they argue but the cheeseburgers protein
all stuff oh yeah and then i'd buy a
thing of peanut butter later
and then i would you know like i was
broke i was broke broke but could you
i couldn't spend three dollars on a on a
burger three
but it's not good for you right it's
like 90 percent of your daily sodium
like you after that you just get sick
and bloated and then you get
oh man you get mud butt from eating that
trash fast fast food yeah no no no no
good
so i would just i'll just have some
tomatoes some tortillas i'd get some
beans and peanut butter
and it would cost me dirt man when you
were when i was when i was flat broke
i figured out a way to get the food that
i needed and i was not eating well
not at all and i've been through a lot
of periods of my life where i was not
eating well and that's part of the
reason why
i'm fairly lefty but i'm also fairly
responsible
so when i got a food cart in seattle
would i i would buy fruit juice with it
i would buy
like protein and peanut butter and i was
what people were telling me like
people would you could just buy
chocolate
chocolate bars double cheese like you
could buy you could buy freezer
cheeseburgers
i'm like yeah but that's why we fix that
right i don't think it can be i mean
because the great you know thomas soil
that when he talks about welfare statism
and
the way that he breaks it down to me is
genius and this way it's broken down to
me and the way i break it down to
everybody else
is that i understand the good intention
right you you have someone that
is down and out and you want them to be
supported in some kind of way
the problem is is that how it's
structured and generally how it's
structured everywhere else
is that you're incentivizing them to
fail because what you do is you say is
so as long as you meet this line
we'll give you whatever it is that you
need
housing food the minute you get above
that line
we're stripping it all away from you and
that's what they're doing you're
incentivizing that's why
a lot of folks that are there stay there
you want you want
what i really love about this i'm
successful
i'm a high school dropout when i talk to
people about how to succeed
and work hard i say if you work hard and
you're smart and you sacrifice you will
succeed they say
tim you're the exception not the rule
but hold on hold on
hold on then when i say you know there
was a period of my life where i
got uh i got welfare i got food stamps
to help me survive they say see it
helped you and then you succeeded
but why aren't i the exception yeah you
see how they play it
yeah so i actually use that argument i
say like i think for me it's a good
example of how it works
i i moved to seattle i had you know some
some
some you know bad stuff came up i ran
out of money
and so i got some food help i
immediately got a job at a local cafe
and then i immediately got off of it i
had it for about a month and
a bunch of other people man a lot of
people that i that i you know knew
in seattle were they purposefully didn't
want to work yeah they would go food
bank to food bank they would just make
up lies and excuses to get their
benefits and stuff like that
and so i don't know what you know i'm
not gonna i can only speak for my own
personal experiences
but i'll point out when i try and tell
people i'm not the exception when it
comes to hard work and success
not in the least bit okay you want to
work for three years with no days off
16-hour days trust me you'll figure
something out yeah as long as you're
dedicated to doing something and making
it work
i understand not everybody's going to
succeed okay but but it's certainly not
an exception to say
working hard leads to something not at
all i mean that's the common theme that
you've seen with a lot of people i mean
i grew up in a single-parent household
mother didn't have uh
uh too much of anything i remember
wearing the same ivanson shoes for a
couple couple of years even though i was
growing um no that's a real thing
but my mother worked my mother was
working two three jobs at a time
just to try to get me to do stuff that i
wanted to do but i'm am i the exception
to the
the food card thing then well i would
well that's an argument to be made and i
think you are
to be completely honest because you look
at the how intergenerational poverty
works in this country
right it's not like it's this way uh
mechanism where people
because yes it's true that folks slide
up and down economic classes all the
time that is absolutely true that is
irrefutable
unfortunately a lot of people don't talk
about it enough but when you talk about
people that are considered
in in poverty the reason why that term
intergenerational poverty exists
is because it's exactly that when you
have someone that comes in poor
remains poor and to sit up here and
think that and this is what what
actually frustrates me as someone that
came from that style of living i grew up
banging
there's nothing that anybody can tell me
about living living that particular
lifestyle
and to see folks that include my own
father
to see folks that didn't do everything
it was that they could do
to get out of that situation was what
kind of changed my mind obviously as i
gotten older because i'm outworking the
people that are right next to me
and they say well they're going to give
it to me anyway the money uh
section 8 housing or whatever it is that
that i have that i'm getting i want to
stay
exactly where i am at and this is why
when we talk about welfare and we talk
about needs and we talk about necessity
i certainly understand all of those
arguments and there's absolutely
arguments to be made
but to sit here and act like every
single person that is
in that particular position it doesn't
really matter if you're poor or rich
but certainly when we talk just to make
it unique to this conversation
if you're talking about those to act
like it's every like they've number one
done everything they could get out of it
is horse crap but most importantly let's
not talk as if there aren't people that
done everything they could to get into
that and to remain exactly where they
are
when my father speaks to them thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you